c'est l'histoire de mylène
nico dominé cette histoire de muriel
garcia main pour de briller
de la journée
il quitte la famille qui l'envoyaient au
péril de leur vie
vt bancaire
on réfléchit souffler jeunesse les
bayonnais étaient confinés et sebo k -o
étaient conviés au goûter la vie
non mais
armé de mingue anglais ne passe presque
usain
il soigne nos êtres aimés au corps
contaminés que je vais m'isoler voiture
vandalisée
pour nos mains a touché une veille
shalit
mais t'es mort qu'à y réfléchisse oublie
tout le reste mais paille où elle est
confinée et ses bords cailloux
[Musique]
été confirmée mais tel aviv au lendemain
ponty que tu aimes en cailloux
réfléchissez play to business b bayonne
était confiné mettait bercail mais on
réfléchit et mettez la ville
oh
en en main bon dieu